sólo quería compartir con ustedes mi
historia con khan academy mi nombre es
sony y estoy empezando mi décimo quinto
año de enseñanza en este otoño empecé en
chicago enseñé en quinto grado por cinco
años y luego me mudé a san diego enseño
en sexto por un año y ahora voy para
nueve años en la escuela primaria de
faith
siempre he enseñado todas las materias
en los grupos en los que he estado ahora
tengo 24 alumnos en el área este de palo
alto y entonces la primaria de inside es
única en eso atiende una población que
es diferente de nuestras comunidades
vecinas sé que otras escuelas probaron
khan academy pero esos estudiantes lucen
muy diferentes de los nuestros ahora
tenemos alrededor de 360 estudiantes de
los cuales todos serán los primeros de
sus familias en ir a la universidad
ellos no están representados lo
suficiente en educación superior y no
saben muy bien el camino para llegar a
la universidad así que nuestra escuela
trajo una secundaria a su comunidad para
que ellos no tuvieran que trasladarse y
que en sus propios barrios pudieran
tener un plan de estudios
competitivo con rigor y vigor que los
llevará a las licenciaturas hasta ahora
ha funcionado y es simplemente un lugar
increíble como maestra al igual que
todos ustedes hice lo mejor que pude
para enseñarles a mis alumnos lo que se
supone tenían que aprender pero lo que
he descubierto en estos años
como profesora es que en realidad me
había dedicado a perfeccionar la manera
en que enseñaba los contenidos y no
cuántos alumnos estaban realmente
aprendiendo
y hacer eso nunca me hizo sentir del
todo bien
y yo amo la relación con mis estudiantes
adoro ser su maestra pero en lo que me
sentía culpable casi todos los días
prácticamente todos los días era saber
que no había llenado las necesidades de
todos ellos y si lo pensaba demasiado
era muy doloroso para soportarlo así que
hacía ese pensamiento a un lado y
continuaba con lo que siempre había
hecho cuando ha sido profesora por 15
años conoces tu material y sabes lo que
esperas y lo que vas a enseñar después
así que puedes ponerte cómoda y después
observaba mi grupo que se parecía a este
y me sentía bien porque estaba haciendo
simpática y estaba haciendo algo
realmente creativo y terminaba mi clase
con una sonrisa porque lo había logrado
sin embargo yo lo había logrado pero que
habían obtenido en mis alumnos y era en
ese momento donde yo podía honestamente
decir que alguna parte de mí no se
preocupaba lo suficiente para
preguntarme que estaba enseñando que
estaban aprendiendo mis alumnos
y cargar con esa sensación no era bueno
y no sé cuántos de ustedes comparten eso
conmigo pero pensaba que estaba dando un
mal servicio a muchos de ellos y sabía
que no podía seguir haciendo lo mismo
así que había tratado de diferenciar
como todos ustedes pero no podía seguir
así como dijo tal era insostenible tener
tres grupos y hacer tres planes de
estudios y hablar con tres grupos de
padres simplemente era imposible podía
hacerlo por dos semanas pero luego se
desvanecían en la nada y al poco tiempo
volvíamos con este tipo de enseñanza
sabía que había chicos en la clase que
estaban muy aburridos sabía que había
algunos que estaban totalmente perdidos
como lo vimos en la diapositiva de
maurienne y por muchos años simplemente
ignore eso porque no sabía qué hacer y
sentía que era imposible lograrlo porque
era la única maestra en el salón
y entonces khan academy vino a nuestra
escuela hace dos años y preguntó si
estábamos dispuestos a ser parte de un
programa piloto y como saben todos los
nuestros decimos que nuestro verano es
muy preciado y sabíamos que eso
implicaba trabajo y como saben tengo un
montón de cosas que hacer incluyendo
tratar de divertirme así que dije tíos
no no creo que puedo hacer eso
pero cuando escuché más sobre eso
también fui a un taller justo como este
pero era más pequeño y el equipo de khan
academy quienes crearon el proyecto
estuvieron aquí hablándonos sobre su
potencial y empecé a entusiasmarme y
pensé que esto podría ser importante
pero como lo uses en un salón cómo lo
haces real podrían darme un paquete con
instrucciones para el día 1 2 y 3 pero
no teníamos eso en ese momento y se
trataba de crearlo yo misma con mis
colegas eso era intimidante y super
abrumador y eso me asustaba demasiado
sin embargo sabía que como maurín decía
tenía que empezar algo y me comprometí
con eso el equipo de khan academy me
prometió que mi manera de enseñar
cambiaría de un salón centrado en el
maestro a uno centrado en el alumno
y que en vez de ser el portador de toda
la información como el sabio de la
escena podría convertirme en la guía a
un lado
y si estás al lado de ellos puedes
apoyarlos hablarles y conocer sus
necesidades por kim no por 13 años
enseñe como el sabio en escena ellos
aprendían lo que yo les enseñaba y lo
aprendían cuando yo estaba lista para
enseñarles
todo era sobre mí tan vergonzoso como
suena pero es la verdad y bien en estos
dos años con khan academy han
significado dejar atrás mi control sobre
el grupo desinflar me y quitarme del
camino para que mis alumnos aprendan por
sí mismos
a través de este proceso de aprendiz que
había subestimado la habilidad de un
chico para aprender por sí mismo
mucho de esto dependía de mí y tal vez
por eso yo había estado tan tensa todos
estos años pero realmente decir si me
quito del camino
ellos podrán defenderse solos y aprender
y yo quiero disculparme con todos ellos
por pensar que yo era la fuente de todo
el conocimiento mi proceso de
implementación de khan academy empezó
muy lento poco a poco en realidad ha
sido en tres etapas y este año va a
iniciar la cuarta etapa la primera etapa
era solo khan academy a un lado era como
me rehúso a dejar que invadan mi
territorio pero sabía que quería al
menos tenerlo en mi salón así que solo
dos veces a la semana por 45 minutos les
decía chicos solo entra en la canaca de
mi vayan a la computadora y hagan
algunos ejercicios empiecen desde arriba
en el mapa de conocimiento con la suma y
sigan
antes y eso me hace sentir bien porque
aún así en lo mío ellos hacían lo suyo y
no había un traslape y después fuimos a
la fase 2 que empezó en el segundo
semestre de ese primer año así que
decidí incorporarlo a mi unidad o sea si
estaba viendo la unidad de las
fracciones entonces así una lista de
reproducción de todos los modelos de
fracciones que encontraba en khan
academy todos los vídeos y luego dejaba
que los estudiantes trabajarán dentro de
esa unidad al ritmo que ellos
necesitaran
y si terminaban temprano podían resolver
el cuestionario pero tenían que quedarse
en las fracciones así que hacíamos un
proyecto con las fracciones podíamos
hacer un poco de trabajo en equipo era
como soltar un poco el control pero no
del todo y eso se sentía muy bien y se
sentía bien porque aún sabía en donde
estaban todos mis alumnos y sabía dónde
nos moveríamos de acuerdo a mi
planeación dependiendo del mapa
curricular
yo sabía muy bien del fondo que había
mucho más potencial del que estaba
haciendo con una unidad a la vez y así
nos fuimos de lleno al programa centrado
en los alumnos esto significa que los
iba a dejar encargarse de todo el
aprendizaje así que al principio del año
tenía todas las unidades expuestas y las
tenía colgadas alrededor del salón y los
alumnos podían trasladarse a su propio
ritmo a través del plan de matemáticas o
sexto año y les voy a compartir un poco
sobre cómo lo establece pero primero
quiero hablar sobre mi compromiso con el
aprendizaje combinado en vez del
aprendizaje tradicional centrado en el
maestro el aprendizaje combinado toma lo
mejor de lo que el maestro puede ofrecer
y lo mejor de la tecnología disponible y
los combina para que puedan maximizar el
poder de los dos cuando estoy dando una
clase de cómo multiplicar decimales y
mover el punto y no te preocupes como
sucede solo muévelo cuando enseñó eso de
hecho pierdo el tiempo pierdo el tiempo
porque sal puede enseñarlo en ese vídeo
o un compañero puede enseñarlo por eso
mi tiempo se aprovecha mejor en guiar a
los chicos
a través de cosas reales hablando de
ello debatiendo resolviendo problemas y
decidí que eso iba a utilizar mi tiempo
porque mucho se desperdicia en algo que
los chicos pueden hacer por sí mismos lo
que me queda de mí es simplemente un
recurso de tantos que hacen un plan de
estudios combinado la gente a menudo
piensa que khan academy lo es todo y que
va a reemplazar mi enseñanza y que me
voy a hacer a un lado que ya no importa
más o se preguntan cómo khan academy
puede ser todo es sólo un montón de
ejercicios esto no es la manera de
enseñar matemáticas pero la realidad es
lo que estoy aprendiendo y aún estoy
aprendiendo es que simplemente una
rebanada del pastel está todo el resto
del pastel que los maestros tenemos el
reto de proporcional
en vez dar estas fantásticas lecciones
sobre cosas que los chicos puedan
aprender solos ahora tienen tiempo y
tienen la libertad de hacer otros
proyectos de pensar en maneras de
conectar las matemáticas con otros
contenidos establecer grupos pequeños
enseñar muchas lecciones realmente
dirigir a los chicos que necesitan ayuda
yo solo pensé eso porque yo luchaba con
cuánta relevancia debía darle a khan
academy en mi enseñanza y encontré su
lugar definitivamente solo un lugar y no
el todo
mi plan de estudios de matemáticas para
sexto está dividido en seis unidades y
empieza con estadísticas relaciones
numéricas fracciones decimales
porcentajes razones tasas y geometría en
el primer día los chicos entran y todo
eso está colgado en el salón con estos
grandes pósters los llamo países y este
año podría usar planetas y entonces
ellos entran y ven en estos países
colgados en el techo y les digo que este
año nuestro trayecto a través de las
matemáticas será viajar a esos países y
ellos los miran y dicen oh ya saben como
sorprendidos los haces muy coloridos y
divertidos y les dices cada país
representa una unidad y que ellos son
responsables de ir a cada uno de ellos y
como lo demuestran tendrán un pin o un
pin con su nombre que colocan para
demostrar en qué unidad están al
principio del año todos empezaron en el
país de datos y estadísticas porque
mediamos por ejemplo nuestros pies
nos conocíamos mejor de esa manera y
después de pasar por ahí movían su pin
al siguiente y es donde las cosas se
complican un poco en la manera anterior
los chicos estaban atrapados en ese país
hasta que todos terminarán y no me
importaba que estuvieran aburridos
porque no estoy lista para que continúe
pero de esta forma ellos pueden mover su
pin
y yo tengo que tener el material listo
por adelantado para que eso sea posible
así que hay mucho que preparar por
adelantado pero al final se gana mucho
ellos cruzaban estos países solos y
siempre tenían un parámetro para saber
dónde estaban en la clase
pero nadie los estaba juzgando
me niego a dejar que sea algo que haga
sentir avergonzado a alguien lo que se
pueda rodear por eso entonces todo el
ámbito de la comunidad en clase y el
establecimiento de un lugar seguro y la
aceptación de eso todos aprenden
diferentes tu fortaleza es mi debilidad
y mi fortaleza es tu debilidad desde el
primer momento establece es que no
importa dónde estén mientras hayan lo
mejor desde donde estén
para mí la construcción de la comunidad
es lo primero que hago cuando empiezo un
ciclo escolar y luego cuando todos
terminan un país lo firman hacen una
fiesta de firmas y lo firman con
plumones metálicos y eso les da la
sensación del logro y después tienen una
fiesta para festejar que terminaron y
que pueden seguir
ahora están pensando bien lo entiendo
pero qué están haciendo los chicos y
como los apoyos durante su recorrido por
esos países necesitan darles algo porque
de otro modo ellos no saben qué hacer
así que establezco algo concreto
un material físico
un mapa una lista de reproducción de las
clases para guiarlos y si tienes eso
ellos pueden ser independientes si no
tienen por qué preguntar qué hay que
hacer en ese esteban y lo que tiene es
una carpeta de khan academy también
tiene su diario de khan academy tiene su
computadora y su propio cerebro
esta es su manera de llevar un registro
de su aprendizaje cada unidad tiene una
carpeta de diferente color y al final
del año él tenía esparcidas seis
carpetas coloridas
y en la noche de portafolio cuando sus
padres y otras personas vinieron él pudo
enseñarles cada unidad que estudió los
cuestionarios al principio y al final de
cada una los ejercicios que hizo y los
extendió con tanto orgullo ellos
cuidaban de esas carpetas ya saben a
veces las carpetas se maltratan pero
ellas las cuidaban y las organizan muy
bien porque eran importantes
estos son algunos de los documentos que
tenían en su carpeta la lista de
reproducción y ustedes probablemente ya
van a poder hacerlo todo desde la página
de khan academy pero yo tenía que
hacerlo a la antigua escribir todo
copiar y pegar y los alumnos empezaban a
subrayar con un marcador lo que habían
logrado lo que habían terminado en ese
tiempo con khan academy y les encanta
eso de marcar algo tiene el hecho de
marcar algo para establecer que ya lo
lograste lo subrayaban y se enseñaban
unos a otros en donde iban y al final
está todo lleno arrugado subrayado pero
ya terminaron así que lo guardan y dicen
son y ya estoy listo para el examen
y yo ya te pasaste y ellos no mejor voy
a repasar y no tienes que darles una
guía de repaso porque tienen los
ejercicios de khan academy y ellas saben
que les costó trabajo con que batallaron
así que pueden simplemente regresar y
hacer re pasos y cuando están listos me
lo dicen
su diario es un gran lugar para llevar
registro de su trabajo y también es un
gran lugar para que yo pueda ver qué
están haciendo y lo que y lo que han
hecho algunos maestros prefieren hacerlo
en el pizarrón y lo van borrando pero
esto me ayuda a tenerlo todo junto y no
volverme loca y ellos pueden revisarlo
cuando se les olvida algo
y trabajan de manera independiente
ahora se están viendo vídeos
a veces están en el piso relajados
aprendiendo juntos
es algo que los une mucho
y luego cuando se atoran por decir ellos
trabajan individualmente yo estoy con un
grupo pequeño de chicos que están
atorados y que me di cuenta al ver el
registro pero los chicos también pueden
conseguir ayuda de otras maneras lo que
está pasando aquí
es que cristian se dio cuenta de que
está atorado y en el pizarrón tenemos un
apartado de necesito ayuda y puedo
ayudar y él sólo va y pone su nombre en
el lado izquierdo y escribe el ejercicio
en que está atorado y los chicos lo ven
de vez en cuando y si ellos ya lo saben
y lo entienden bien van y ponen su
nombre en el otro lado y lo tachan y van
directo con el compañero y comienzan a
ayudarle como una asesoría entre pares
esto realmente libera al profesor
entonces en lugar de que sea como en el
vídeo de tal que lo vimos ir de un lado
a otro tú te puedes concentrar en tu
grupo pequeño y esto tiene como una vida
propia y tal vez se están preguntando
como yo me lo preguntaba bueno y que les
están enseñando lo están haciendo bien y
ya saben a lo mejor a veces no lo
enseñan de la mejor manera sólo le dicen
tú pon esto acá y ya sin explicar las
cosas pero yo creo que otras veces
realmente asumiendo el rol seriamente y
usaban el vocabulario matemático
para enseñarles
y a veces yo tenía que decirles ya deja
de ayudar a la gente y es tu propio
trabajo y al tener que decirle a alguien
ya deja de ayudar a los demás
yo pensaba un momento que acabo de decir
realmente les gusta esto de ayudarse
unos a otros y tener la sensación de
hacer algo bueno por alguien más y al
mismo tiempo reafirmar lo que ellos
pueden hacer la asesoría entre pares es
algo que está pasando al mismo tiempo
todo el tiempo se sientan uno al lado
del otro en la misma banca eso fue muy
lindo ellos normalmente no se llevaban
pero estaban en la misma banca
ayudándose y una parte del salón está
reservada para que los que están
haciendo el examen como cada quien
avanza a su propio paso unos terminan
las unidades más rápido que otros así
que estos chicos dijeron ya estoy listo
para el examen se van a una parte del
salón que establecía al principio ponen
una barrera y comienzan a hacer la
prueba
se concentran yo estaba preocupada al
principio que con nosotros hablando iba
a ser muy difícil pero no las arreglamos
en un día típico puede que se estén
trabajando dos o tres unidades
simultáneamente en este día unos estaban
en relaciones entre números otros habían
pasado a fracciones y yo estaba dando
mini clases a esos grupos de alumnos y
al mismo tiempo hay asesoría entre ellos
y bien
que me quede me no lo es todo y ya que
sólo una parte con que ya en el resto
del tiempo los chicos trabajan con khan
academy tres veces a la semana por una
hora y media cada día
hago calendario en bloques así que en
esos días no les doy ciencias en la
tarde pero en los otros días de la
semana
doy lección al grupo entero también a
elección grupal de matemáticas te das
cuenta de cuánto es necesario hacerlo
para mi era al ver el registro escuchar
sus preguntas y ver con qué estaban
batallando
también nos duele el tiempo grupal para
hablar sobre los proyectos que hace todo
el grupo sin importar en qué unidad se
encuentren y yo estaba equivocada cuando
pensé que sólo iban a poder manejar una
unidad a la vez pero no fue así y fue
una sorpresa muy agradable ver que
incluso si un chico todavía estaba en el
país de las fracciones podía hacer un
proyecto sobre porcentajes con la ayuda
de otros y a menudo eso también les
ayudaba con su unidad de fracciones así
que me di cuenta de que no tenía que
esperar de esta manera lineal a terminar
con una cosa antes de empezar la
siguiente que podía aprender varias
cosas a la vez realmente estaba pasando
otra vez los estaba subestimando use
cuadernos de matemáticas especialmente
para los que les interese enseñarles a
escribir matemáticas y que puedan
explicar su pensamiento ese era un
componente de mi clase también de nuevo
clase grupal o en grupos pequeños
accesorio individual o entre padres y
también hay proyectos que se van
trabajando dependiendo de la unidad
en que nos encontremos y luego tenemos
las habilidades para resolver problemas
específicos yo le llamo el plan de
resolución de problemas en el que pasan
por los seis pasos de resolución de
problemas y todo esto junto es como
evaluó a los alumnos
alguien me preguntaba qué hago cuando no
todos terminan
es algo que no podía responder cuando
empecé con esto y tampoco tengo una
respuesta completa ahora pero lo que les
puedo decir es que lo se evaluaba con
los proyectos y todos los demás
componentes pero no recibieron una
evaluación de khan academy
eso sólo era para practicar a su propio
ritmo las proteínas se evaluaba y eran
parte de la calificación pero solo hasta
donde se hubieran
quedado entonces al final del año en
junio cuando hacemos las boletas y
calculamos todas sus calificaciones
algunos alumnos habían hecho seis
pruebas como parte de su evaluación y
otros sólo tenían tres yo tengo la
flexibilidad por mi escuela y ya sé que
no todos de poder extender el año
escolar tenía como seis alumnos que no
habían terminado todos los países así
que lo que hicimos fue mandar una nota a
sus padres y ellos siguieron viniendo
dos semanas más
venían de 8 a 12 en junio y sólo era
khan academy y ya sé que esto no parece
realista pero yo tenía el verano
libre y bueno ya saben no tengo vida
estaba libre así que estaba libre para
hacer esto y la escuela estuvo
disponible y los chicos querían venir a
hacerlo también podían venir después de
la escuela el laboratorio estaba abierto
de 5 a 10 todas las noches porque muchos
de nuestros alumnos no tienen
computadora en casa no tienen internet
sus padres no pueden ayudarlos así que
la escuela necesita estar abierta hasta
las 10 ellos venían y lo hacían me
preguntaban si podían ir los sábados o
los domingos
saben cada academia y realmente logra
motivarlos al ser auto dirigido y a su
propio ritmo ellos realmente quieren
acabarlo
así que tenían muchas ganas de venir a
la escuela y terminar con esto yo tuve
que modificar las unidades para hacerlas
un poco más cortas así que en lugar de
tres ejercicios de multiplicación de
decimales o lo que fuera solo hacían dos
así que acorte la lista para incluir
solo las habilidades indispensables y
saqué los que eran extras para que
funcionaran y pudieran terminar así que
terminaron pero todavía está en proceso
porque este año es la fase 4 estoy
tratando de añadir cosas o cambiar otras
dependiendo de cómo funcionaron el año
pasado es algo que se está desarrollando
todavía pero es emocionante ser parte de
esto es emocionante hacer algo que de
verdad siento que es la esencia de la
enseñanza enseñarle a cada alumno no
solo al grupo
y me encanta que estén aquí para unirse
a
este gran proyecto y crear su propio
viaje de enseñanza para sus alumnos así
que muchas gracias